you knew George and you you performed
that song with George I think I'd
starting out live in 1976 if I'm not
wrong
yes yeah my I'm not sure of the date but
yeah in the center one of the second
year maybe second year Saturday Night
Live yeah I had the I got the amazing
pleasure of meeting him once when I was
at starting out live he came by good
friends with Lauren Michaels and he came
by and I got to meet him briefly which
was one of the great moments of my life
and then flash-forward many years I
become friends with Danny Harrison and
the last time I was in London just a
couple of weeks ago he invited me over
to friar Park the very famous house
where George lived you know for such a
good chunk of his life and he's in that
house you can see it's such a big his
spirit is there it's such an amazing
place you've gone you went to friar Park
and you visited George we knew yeah we
visited there he was he was an
extraordinary guy as everybody people
know everybody knows that yeah amazing
person that's just as a musician but
really very very open kind not you know
just a certain percentage of them
Beatles and then the rest of just
regular interested in life interested in
the world interested in the mind really
pleasure pleasure to hang out with him
did you guys just would you play it all
together he he you know he had all he
had lots of ukuleles around he loved to
play ukulele yeah and so you just give
you know give you a ukulele and say you
know let's let's play you know so yeah
you did he had a great jukebox to
jukebox full of all the music that he
listened to when he was a kid which is
pretty much what I listen to it's just
like slight English variation on it
though but otherwise the same that
jukebox is still there and I was looking
through it it was just so amazingly
personal to see this is the stuff yeah
anyways maybe this is what he wanted to
listen to when he was hanging around the
house and I thought that was so
like I say you got a sense of the man
and it's it's still there his ukuleles
are still there his guitars from Beatles
and the solo years and it's all there
and it's a great there's a real there's
a lot of love in that house and yes of
course and also the the grounds that it
would he had he had a lot of you know he
had a lot of acreage and he was really
very fussy about it himself you know I
mean he would we'd cross a pond and if
there was something stopping up the you
know the flow of some little creek into
it he'd get in there and pull it out he
loved it he designed things oh he said
this was I love dis he said that when
you draw it when you drive in there are
these enormous boulders and I said I
said is that a sculpture or are they you
know is that natural and the property
and he said no they were on the property
but we brought him here and we put him
in this this field over here and like
right around that time Paul McCartney
had put out a an album called a standing
stone and George said but when Ringo
came here to visit
he said when Ringo asked me about the
stones he said I said to Ringo oh yeah
Paul sent that to us as a promo for us
great Ringo said he didn't send that
[Laughter]
you